[Music]
this is what the skies looked like in
March and this was one month later when
passenger numbers were staggering 94
percent lower than the previous year
thanks to the covert 19 pandemic
business is now starting to pick up
but Travel is becoming increasingly
localized and complicated this world of
quite easy travel and relatively free
movement just sort of vac has evaporated
almost overlaid this will have
consequences far beyond canceled holiday
bookings it could exacerbate existing
inequalities create economic hardship
and disrupt the workings of the
globalized world the tourism industry is
enormous
every year international holiday makers
spend 1.6 trillion dollars that's more
than Spain's GDP
or at least they did before the corona
virus pandemic the CDC just told
everyone do not travel postpone or
cancel all non-essential travel
in April twenty twenty planes carried
just 31 million passengers around the
world the sort of passenger levels last
seen in the late 1970s in April this
year 200,000 passengers went through
Heathrow Airport in London which is
fewer than would go through on any
single day in a normal month
Yatta the airline trade body has said
flights will not return to pre-pandemic
levels for several years in China
flights are now just 21% below normal
levels while in America air traffic
began to pick up in May but remains 57
percent below normal and in much of
Europe flight numbers are still around
75 percent lower than the same time last
year
and while passenger numbers are creeping
up at some areas like business travel
may never recover after the last
financial crisis the number of overseas
business trips taking per person in the
UK fell by a third and never picked up
whereas leisure travel did eventually
climb back to pre-crisis levels were the
same thing to happen again it could have
a significant impact on airline profits
business travellers actually subsidized
leisure travelers your 250-pound
transatlantic affair in the back of the
plane is possible because somebody at
the front of the plane is paying 800 or
1,500
airlines are already struggling Virgin
Atlantic has announced plans to cut more
than 3,000 jobs in the UK air canada
lost more than a billion dollars in the
first quarter in march
Yatta warned that without government aid
just 30 of the world's 700 or so
airlines would make it through the
pandemic the airlines that survive will
determine the competition and prices on
certain routes some airlines are in
pretty good financial shape within
Europe there remains a lot of
competition transatlantic flights there
is still plenty of competition but all
routes where there's much thinner
competition prices will go up there's no
doubt about that for the well-off the
price increases may be an annoyance but
they could also have a significant
impact on global mobility as lower
income travelers may find themselves
priced out of the skies what happens
with FS and with the prices of flights
effects not just summer holidays
migrants have parents or spouses in one
country and work in another and for all
of these people it is quite important
that they continue to be able to go home
in June 189 countries had imposed some
form of travel restriction ranging from
measures like quarantine to border
closures
and governments are desperate open up
travel as quickly as possible the
government is to make it easier for
British holiday makers to travel to much
of Europe this summer
though these arrangements may help
tourists they could also create an
increasingly inequitable system the
British government is working to allow
Brits to go off on holiday to say it
Spain or France and come back without
the need for quarantine but that doesn't
take into account the fact that someone
may have a partner in America parents in
Nigeria or siblings in Pakistan and they
won't be able to go see people have
anything important to them the risk is
that we end up with a very uneven and
possibly unfair system the relatively
free movement enjoyed by many tourists
is a modern phenomenon that has played
an increasingly important role in
globalization and domestic economies
take China for around 30 years until the
end of the 1970s travel to and from
China was heavily restricted but today
China sends more tourists aboard in any
other country and they spend more money
in 2018 Chinese tourists spent over two
hundred and seventy billion dollars
overseas almost double that spent by
Americans and the limitations on travel
caused by the pandemic can have a
knock-on effect on global cooperation
and economic growth the worry is that
these these restrictions persist in the
long term and then become entangled in
all sorts of other things such as
reciprocity trade negotiations any sort
of geopolitical dispute between
countries and so we return to sort of
mid twentieth century world of closed
borders lots of restrictions and
paperwork and just less interchange
between countries
faced with an ever-changing array of
travel restrictions many travelers are
looking closer to home for their
holidays in May 80% of total
reservations on Airbnb were made
domestically and between January and
April foreign searches for summer
holiday accommodation in Spain fell by
as much as 94 percent the rise in
localized travel could be good news for
the environment in 2018 carbon dioxide
emissions from commercial flights
accounted for 2.4 percent of global
fossil fuel emissions the answer to this
quandary is not to stop people from from
flying rather it's to make planes more
efficient and to focus on innovation in
the industry the band directors
accelerated the shift towards efficiency
so some older planes are being taken out
of the sky the covert 19 pandemic would
dramatically affect the way in which
people move around the world but rather
than driving economic growth as the
travel industry has in the past new
restrictions could affect globalization
sewing division and increasing
inequality my name is Leo Maroney I'm a
correspondent on the Britain desk at the
Economist and if you'd like to read more
about the impact that Pope 19 is having
an international travel click the link
opposite